in today's business landscape embracing
cutting-edge Technologies is Paramount
to staying ahead among these Innovations
Cloud migration strategies emerge as a
Celestial Beacon guiding Enterprises to
efficiency scalability and success
Recent research by industry experts show
that an astounding 94 of Enterprises
have adopted Cloud Solutions with 84
implementing a multi-cloud approach
businesses seek not just a change of
scenery but a revolution in their I.T
infrastructure where the cloud offers
inexhaustible opportunities so join us
in this new video on cloud migration
strategies as we journey through the
cloud in shrouded Realms of cloud
migration strategies we'll explore
Pathways empowering businesses to
transcend conventional I.T setups and
embrace cloud-based agility security and
cost efficiency discover how Cloud
migration strategy energies expedite
digital transformation leading to a
remarkable 20 reduction in it cost
worldwide so let's take flight into the
Imperial realm of cloud migration
strategies where boundless opportunities
awaits those daring enough to embrace
the future of business transformation
but before that if you want to explore
and learn more about interesting
concepts of cloud computing like Cloud
migration strategies then simply learns
Caltech postgraduate program in cloud
computing will be the one for you this
cloud computing program is designed to
help you become an expert in Azure AWS
and gcp this in-depth cloud computing
certification course lets you master key
architectural principles and develop the
skills needed to become a cloud expert
this postgraduate program in cloud
computing will help you become an expert
in designing planning scaling Cloud
implementation and help you master the
core skill sets required to design and
deploy dynamically scalable and rely
applications on three popular Cloud
platform providers Microsoft Azure AWS
and gcp so to explore more and enroll
now you can click on the course link
mentioned in the description so now
let's move on to the video first let's
start from the basics and understand
what is a cloud migration strategy
well Cloud migration strategy is the
planned approach for transferring
existing ID resources and services from
on-premises to Cloud platforms like AWS
Azure or gcp
it involves assessment selecting the
right Cloud Model migrating data and
applications and continuous monitoring
the strategy aims to achieve benefits
like increased flexibility scalability
and cost efficiency Cloud migration
strategy involves assessment planning
and choosing the right cloud model like
public private or hybrid data and
applications are then migrated with
testing and staff training to ensure a
smooth transition benefits include
improve accessibility disaster recovery
and reduce infrastructure maintenance so
now let's explore why companies should
embrace a cloud migration strategy well
picture this it helps them identify the
fastest most cost effective and least
disruptive path to the cloud
moreover it acts as a campus to
determine which existing application
workloads should be discontinued
Rewritten retained on-premises moved as
into a cloud platform or enhanced with
Native cloud services
it's like having a road map to
successful Cloud adoption so what are
the main benefits of migrating to the
cloud well you won't believe how awesome
this is first off we have scalability
which means cloud computing can
effortlessly support larger workloads
and cater to more users than traditional
on-premises setups no more buying and
setting up physical servers folks and
let's not forget about the cost savings
Cloud providers offer managed services
that reduce operational overhead and
simplify maintenance tasks this allows
companies to allocate more resources to
Innovation fostering the development of
new and improved products
but that's not all performance gets a
major boost to migrating to the cloud
can enhance application performance and
end user experience significantly
with the ability to easily scale
applications and host them closer to end
users Network latency become a thing of
the past and here comes the digital
experience
cloud services allow users to access
data and applications from anywhere
whether they are employees or customers
this paves the way for digital
transformation delivering an
unparalleled experience to both
customers and employees with modern and
flexible tools so let's dive into the
mechanics now how does a cloud migration
strategy actually work
so when formulating migration strategies
organizations need to begin by
thoroughly assessing the architecture
and requirements of each application
which also considering the available
skills budget and timeline to achieve
the desired objectives the initial step
involves evaluating the current setup to
understand the majority of each workload
which may necessitate a comprehensive
Discovery phase for all instances of
existing application subsequently the
migration process should be meticulously
planned with well-defined Milestones
clear objectives reasonable time frames
for each task and a comprehensive risk
analysis to address potential challenges
during the migration of workloads to
ensure a successful migration it is
essential to incorporate a pilot project
starting with the re-hosting or
relocating task this facilitates the
identification of any uncover gaps and
allow for necessary adjustments as the
migration progresses while executing a
large-scale migration requires a focus
on 3 key optimization points tailoring
applications and instances for Optimal
Performance during Peak usage
maintaining a strong emphasis on
operations and governance throughout the
migration process and developing the
required expertise to establish a
marriage Services team responsible for
overseeing the migration and subsequent
operations
well by adhering to these guidelines
organizations can streamline their
migration efforts and increase the
likelihood of a successful and smooth
transition to the desired environment
now hold on tight because here comes the
exciting part we have got seven Cloud
migration strategies so there are seven
primary strategies for cloud migration
known as the 7 hours organizations
seeking to migrate to the cloud must
carefully access their needs to
determine which strategy best suits them
so below is a concise description of
each approach first is rehost rehost or
lift and shift here an application is
migrated to the cloud without making any
significant changes to utilize
cloud-specific features
second is relocate hypervisor level lift
and shift this approach involves
Shifting the infrastructure to the cloud
without requiring new hardware
application rewrites or adjustments to
current operations
Technologies like VMware Cloud
facilitate this migration method
third is re-platform now this is known
as lift and reshape with this approach
an application is transferred to the
cloud while incorporating optimizations
to take advantage of cloud capabilities
for this
repurchase drop and Shop in this
strategy an organization transitions to
a different product often adopting a
software as a service model instead of
traditional licensing and fifth is
refactor or G platform list and reshape
with this approach an application is
transferred to the cloud while
incorporating optimizations to take
advantage of cloud capabilities fifth is
retire with this strategy organizations
discontinue or eliminate applications
that are no longer needed in the source
environment
and sixth is reading that means revisit
the retained strategy involves
maintaining applications in their
original environment this might include
applications that require substantial
refactoring which can be deferred to a
later time or Legacy applications that
remain in place due to lack of business
justification for migration so when
considering a cloud migration
organization should carefully weigh
these strategies to make the most
suitable choice for their specific
requirements but wait there's more so
when you embark on the cloud
transformation Journey there's a
carefully planned sequence of five
phases that you must conquer
first up the prepare phase in this stage
organization establish their businesses
objectives for cloud migration such as
increase agility cost savings improve
performance or enhance scalability they
also conduct an initial assessment of
the I.T infrastructure to understand
what resources can be migrated and what
needs to be addressed beforehand once
the objectives are clear it's time for
the plan phase
now this involves creating a detailed
migration roadmap determining the
preferred Cloud architecture and
addressing any compliance or security
requirements you wouldn't want any
surprises on this journey and now the
moment we have all been waiting for the
migrate fix
now this is where the magic happens as
organizations actually start moving the
applications and data to the cloud it
can involve various techniques like lift
and shift refactoring or even rebuilding
applications from scratch and believe me
the process is closely monitored to
ensure everything goes as planned next
up the operate fees
now this is where organizations manage
their workloads in the cloud environment
continuously monitoring performances
managing resources and maintaining
top-notch security and compliance it's
like piloting your cloud ship through
calm Waters
and finally the optimize phase now as
the name suggests this is all about
refinement and enhancement organizations
look for ways to improve Cloud
operations identify opportunities for
cost savings and Implement Cloud native
features or services to further enhance
performance it's a never-ending quest
for Perfection now as with an exciting
Journey there are challenges to overcome
let's talk about some common Cloud
migration challenges faced by
organizations
one of the significant hurdles is a lack
of strategy some companies jump into
Cloud migration without investing
sufficient time and attention to a well
thought out plan successful Cloud
adoption and implementation require
rigorous end-to-end Cloud migration
planning accounting for different
applications requirements and
consideration and let's forget about
cost management many organizations
struggle to set clear key performance
indicators to understand the anticipated
spending or savings after migration
keeping track of cloud cost can be
tricky since Cloud environments are
Dynamic and cost can change rapidly as
new services are adopted and application
usage grows now comes the infamous
vendor lock-in a cloud migrators Nemesis
while child providers offer a plethora
of services some might not be easily
portable to other Cloud platforms
switching providers can be a lengthy and
costly process so it's essential to
Choose Wisely from the start and last
but not the least data security and
compliance these are critical concerns
during migration cloud services operate
on a shared responsibility model where
the provider secure infrastructure but
the customer must secure their data and
workloads ensuring the correct
configuration of security controls and
handling large volumes of sensitive data
during migration can be challenging so
there you have it
the captivating world of cloud migration
strategy from preparing and planning to
migrating and optimizing this journey
can be transmitted for businesses
unlocking their true potential in the
cloud and to help you realize the true
potential of cloud computing and its
Concepts and how upskilling in cloud
computing can Skyrocket your career
here's a success story of one of our
Learners who actually transformed their
career via our course so do watch it hi
I live in Mumbai and I am the co-founder
and chief digital and Technology officer
of vcns global I wanted to cater to
customer who wanted to take the journey
towards the cloud so I decided to opt
for the post-graduation program in cloud
computing in association with Caltech
from Simply learn so I was learning
every day and implementing my learning
at my business to in real time after I
completed the course I was able to
structure the whole Cloud consultancy
vertical for my company I think it was a
wise decision to take the course and
business time is money so make a wise
investment today well this was it if you
enjoyed this video make sure to hit that
like button and subscribe to our channel
for more Tech insights and don't forget
to share it with your friends if you
have any questions related to this video
then please feel free to ask them in the
comment section our team will reach out
to you as soon as possible until next
time keep exploring the wondrous realm
of Technology thank you and keep
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign